a cracker why are you allowed to call a
ship the unyielding fist but you're not
allowed to call it the [ __ ] rocker
I feel like fisting okay everybody
everybody cross your fingers for some
good frame rates hey I got decent frames
guys you start to push figure it out it
W does that work smack some button with
something and then we are not moving why
I'm on fire ships like a lot of them
right gets her right way left left
you're doing great you're doing great
weight fraction down a smidge down
attack one smidge please smidgen okay I
need some left there ya go don't know we
didn't not that thing what how why you I
waited the rules of basic human
interaction
yes we're dense wha we're dim song for
dim sum we're dumpling we're doubling
down
dumplings we're dumplings mining outpost
okay alright well it's on the other side
wait so if you could just like you down
right more like down and to the right
yeah there we go
I feel like you guys are judging your
good old captain no no good old captain
is learning maybe it's not so easy and
he should have cut me a little baby
captain things seem to be on fire we're
being hit
when I say left I mean like tiny bit
tiny bit there okay turn right turn
right turn right turn right oh [ __ ] my
gun is down I've activated my super oh
nice
my special is up wait I'm gonna get you
I don't think that wait there's a
special not repair oh that explains a
lot
[Applause]
[Music]
why are we who and why aren't we using
faith in you left left is that our
battle cry laugh welcome oh all the guns
are down gotcha thanks man
thanks to bro thanks yeah you know the
objective is sitting at a solid zero out
of six I love it though man wait it's
almost like you were giving me so much
[ __ ] and it's actually not that easy I'm
doing oh but you hit a mountain Wade
don't uh it's really bright in this
mountain
they would not be accurate to say that
this is going well yeah what do you mean
don't question I'm not questioning
criticize it doesn't feel good when you
get questioned as the captain does it
wait good pretty good like not on target
for anything I guess we might as well
take out the mining outpost it does seem
like it's one of our objectives I don't
know Oh proud yeah you're really not
don't lift you know what wait it was
unfair of me to be so harsh on you
you're really I feel like
togetherness is what we really want yeah
I feel like that's the message that we
need to be spreading right now our core
knowledge not how bad weight is doing
how good everyone is doing collectively
balancing out whatever weight is there
was a compliment wait it was a
compliment
it looks like just some like preteen kid
took over captaining on our heroes he
flew left to the end
he did yes